all right today's question comes from
lindsey and georgia this is a big one
i cannot wait to hear what you have to
say about this drone i'm the sole earner
mom of three and three step kids my
income ranges from a hundred thousand to
two hundred thousand we've paid off
two hundred thousand dollars of our
initial three hundred and eighty
thousand dollars of debt in the past
three years
amazing my husband is a stay-at-home dad
and due to covid
and thinks that we should be spending
more money despite getting
200 a week i pay his child support and
his tuition he is a good roommate but a
terrible husband he has withheld all
affection
in the past years and prioritizes
netflix over me
i can withhold spending can i withhold
spending money
until he agrees to work on our marriage
we had counseling
but he would not follow up i'm so
exhausted lonely and depressed
i resent feeling i am good enough to
work
60 hours a week to support him but not
good enough to be
loved oh man
that's about a year it's worth the work
here there so
to answer there's one question in here
which is can i withhold
spending money until he agrees to work
on our marriage
the answer is no no anybody who starts
who gets into the business of
withholding whether that's
i'm withholding affection intimacy i'm
withholding
um information i've got secrets
right i'm withholding um fears i'm
withholding
money mm-hmm that that's that's like
i said even a red flag that's like this
giant neon sign right yeah
this feels like resentment and this
feels like this relationship
it actually feels like this relationship
is over and like you mentioned it
we're roommates now he's got a good deal
i got a good deal
and i'm just exhausted lonely and the
good deal on the roommate stuff is run
out
right um i don't think this is a money
question at all
no so let me just let me go high level
money and then i want you to dig into
this
because i i am curious all of your
thoughts so just a couple of things
lindsay
and again this is all the symptom of a
bigger problem so what i'm about to say
is not going to solve your life
here but even saying his child support
his tuition it it seems like you know i
i give him 200 a week you guys are not a
team
like it is a his and her viewpoint
and a little bit of it sounds like
you're being his mom that's exactly
right and
nobody wants to be nobody wants to have
a romantic relationship with their mom
right i wish there was another way to
say that
but he's being mothered right and
he's acting like a five-year-old who
needs a mom right and so now you get in
this weird dance because he needs to he
needs to
to buck up too like this isn't all your
fault lindsey
we're not picking on you but you do have
to realize
even the language you use shows where
you guys are at in the marriage even
just in the question which is
fascinating okay
so it becomes a dance right it becomes
i feel like she's always telling me what
to do she's acting like my mom
and then that shuts off all desire right
which then leads to i'm just gonna
retreat and hide in front of netflix
and complain about not being able to go
out with my friends
which then he's acting like a
five-year-old and then she has to right
somebody has to say stop somebody's
gotta just
as terry reel says you gotta turn and
stare the forest fire down
you gotta look at both of you've got
stuff in your past that y'all gotta deal
with both of you got six kids in this
house
um you make great money there's a part
of me that believes you think you're
better
than him because he you make that kind
of money there's part of me that thinks
he feels like he's a loser because
there's so much here and at the end of
the day you said it best i'm so
exhausted
lonely and depressed rachel i've heard
that those three words
over and over and over this this season
right
if your partner will not go to
counseling with you if your husband or
wife girlfriend boyfriend won't go
you're left with
one option and that is to control what
you can control and that is to work on
you
so you've got to go right if if
you both had the flu that's probably not
a good if you both had strep throat
and you go fill up both prescriptions
and he won't take his medicine
that doesn't mean you don't take yours
in fact that means you've got to take
yours right because somebody's got to be
well
that's good yeah so spend the time the
money the energy
to get refilled it's not happening here
my hope is my hope for this marriage
is that when she starts working through
the her challenges which are bigger than
him bigger than this mess
that she will get some new skills and
some new tools that will give her some
clarity on her next path
and hopefully will give her some clarity
on how to engage him
a little bit differently that he might
be able to hear it she might
have peace in her heart right she may be
able to start acting outside of this
marriage
and um that sounded weird not act
outside the marriage but start no i hear
yeah yeah
start having like right you're gonna
start exercising again start taking care
of yourself start having friends and
community members go get re-engaged with
a local church or local community groups
or whatever that looks like
and my hope is that your husband will
see that and say i want that
right blaming and criticizing and
yelling never have solved a problem in a
marriage
right and i love that control which you
can control because i think that's one
of the most frustrating things
and like we talked about that you know
even last hour but it's like yeah if you
you yeah you don't have an option right
you're not gonna just like absolutely
drag him you can't physically drag him
and even if you did
and set him in a room with a counselor
he's not going to do any good right he's
not going to he
he he chooses to hear it or not so so
being able to control what you can
control but lindsay i'm so sorry
this is a story for a lot of couples out
there are in this and that's one thing
i'm excited about our event tonight to
hopefully bring
a level of clarity and tools to people
um
because it's tough but thanks lindsay
thanks for your question